[Musique]
du ska déjanté des riffs saturés et un
duo de didgeridoo la musique sous toutes
ses formes à voisins le bretonneux
pour sa première édition le festival la
tour mais les watts s'est offert une
programmation festive et varier un peu
éclectique gérer il ya beaucoup de
styles différents
ça permet de découvrir aussi d'autres
mon style de musique qu'on connaît pas
forcément découvrir de nouveaux goûts et
d'autres de découvrir de nouveaux styles
de nouveaux styles de son de comment les
gens ils vont leur sont tous a donc de
nouveau chante arrosée pas mal une
dizaine de groupes de scène et des
artistes locaux en pleine performance
un événement pour faire revivre l'ancien
festival la tour prend l'air en mettant
à l'honneur musiciens amateurs et
professionnels
ce qui a motivé à lancer ce festival
c'est le
corner la volonté de
de promouvoir les groupes émergents
c'est la plupart c'est les groupes qu'on
a
on a déjà fait jouer à la salle de la
tour e
la volonté c'était vraiment d'offrir un
plein air et redonner ses lettres de
noblesse et oui aux amateurs et puis du
coup avec l'avantagé d'avoir la tête
d'affiche qu'ils puissent rameuter du
monde et qui
à lui me l'a fait quoi et c'est à
hilight tribe qui était destinée cette
tâche locon tête d'affiche très attendu
des visiteurs a clos le festival sur une
note 36 quai des lic
et